We will now apply our
multinomial formula for
counting the number of
partitions to solve the
following probability problem.
We have a standard 52-card
deck, which we
deal to four persons.
Each person gets 13 cards as,
for example, in bridge.
What is the probability
that each person
gets exactly one ace?
Well, before we start, as
always we will need a
probability model.
We deal the cards fairly, and
this is going to be our model.
But we still need to interpret
our statement.
To give this interpretation,
let us first think of the
outcomes of the experiment.
What are the possible
outcomes?
An outcome of this experiment is
a partition of the 52 cards
into the four persons
so that each person
gets exactly 13 cards.
Our statement about dealing the
cards fairly will be an
assumption that all partitions
are equally likely.
So since all partitions, all
outcomes of the experiment,
are equally likely, this means
that we can solve a
probability question
by counting.
We need to count the number of
elements of our sample space,
the number of possible outcomes,
and then count the
number of outcomes that
make the event
of interest to occur.
Let us start with the
number of elements
of the sample space.
This is the problem that
we just dealt with a
little while ago--
the number of outcomes, the
number of partitions of 52
items into four persons, where
we give 13 cards to person
one, 13 cards to person two, 13
cards to person three, and
13 cards to person four.
The number of possible ways of
doing this is equal to this
multinomial coefficient.
So now let us count the number
of outcomes that belong to the
event of interest, namely the
outcomes where each person
gets an ace.
We think of the process of
constructing such an outcome
as a multi-stage process.
And we count the number
of choices that we
have at each stage.
The process is as follows.
We first distribute
the four aces.
We take the ace of spades and
give it to one person.
In how many ways can we do it?
We can do it in four ways.
Then we take the next ace.
The next ace must be given
to a different person.
And so at that stage, we have
three different choices about
who to give that ace to.
Then we consider the next ace.
At this point, two persons
already have aces.
So we have two available
choices for who can
get the next ace.
And finally for the last ace,
we do not have any choice.
We give it to the only remaining
person who doesn't
yet have an ace.
Having distributed the four
aces, then we need to somehow
distribute the remaining 48
cards to the four people.
But we can do that in
any way we want.
So all we need to do is to just
partition the 48 cards
into four subsets of given
cardinalities.
And this can be done by a number
of ways, which is the
number of such partitions.
We have already found
what that number is.
And it is this particular
multinomial coefficient.
So the number of ways that we
can distribute the cards so
that each person gets an ace,
according to the counting
principle, is going to be the
number of ways that we can
distribute the aces times the
distribute the remaining
cards.
The product of this number gives
us the count, gives us
the cardinality, of the
event of interest.
We also have the cardinality
of the sample space.
So the desired probability
can be found by
dividing these two numbers.
And the final answer
takes this form.
Let us now look at the
same problem but
in a different way.
Probability problems can often
be solved in multiple ways.
And some can be faster
than others.
So we want to look for a smarter
solution that perhaps
will get us in a faster way
to the desired answer.
We will use the following
trick.
We will think about a very
specific way of dealing the
cards which is the following.
We take the 52 cards, the card
deck, and stack it so that the
four aces are at the top.
So they are first.
And then we deal those cards
to the players as follows.
We think of each player having
13 slots of his own.
And the cards will be
placed randomly into
the different slots.
So we can do this one card at a
time, starting from the top.
We take the first ace and send
it to a random location.
Then we will take the second
ace, send it to a random
location, and so on.
What we want to calculate is the
probability that the four
aces will end up in locations
or in slots that are
associated with different
persons.
So let us calculate
this probability.
The first ace can go anywhere.
It doesn't matter.
For the second ace, it has
51 slots to choose from.
It's 51 because we started
with 52, but one slot has
already been taken by
that particular ace.
So for the ace of hearts,
we have 51 slots
that it can go to.
And out of those 51, we have
39 of them that belong to
people who do not
yet have an ace.
So this is the probability that
the ace of hearts gets
placed into a slot that belongs
to a person who is
different than the person
who got the first ace.
Now let us consider this ace.
What is the probability that
this ace will get into a slot
which belongs to either this
person or that person?
It has 26 slots in which
this desired
event is going to happen.
And it's 26 out of the
50 available slots.
Finally, let us consider
this ace.
So having placed that ace and
assuming that it got to a
different person, what is the
probability now that this ace
is going to go to this person
who doesn't yet have one?
The probability of this
happening is the number of
slots associated with that
person, which is equal to 13
divided by the number
of slots that this
card can choose from.
And the number of slots is 52
minus the 3 slots that have
already been taken,
so it's 49.
And so this is the answer
to our problem.
This expression looks very
different from the expression
that we derived a
little earlier.
But you can do the algebra, the
arithmetic, simplify the
answer, and you will verify that
indeed it's exactly the
same answer.
And in case you're curious, the
numerical value turns out
to be 0.105.
So there's about 10% [chance]
that when you deal the cards
in bridge, each one of the
players is going to end up
having exactly one ace.
So this was a faster way of
getting to the answer to our
problem, compared to
the previous one.
But it raises a legitimate
question.
Is the way that we dealt the
cards by putting the aces on
top and then dealing them,
is that way a fair way
of dealing the cards?
Is it true that with this way
of dealing the cards all
partitions are equally likely?
It turns out that this
is indeed the case.
But it does require
a bit of thinking.
Maybe you can see
it intuitively
that this is the case.
But if not, then it is something
that one can prove.
It can be proved formally
as follows.
One first needs to check that
all permutations, that is all
possible allocations
of cards into
slots, are equally likely.
And because of this, one can
then argue that any possible
partition into subsets of [13]
is also equally likely.
So this is an equivalent way
of dealing the cards to the
one that we considered earlier,
which was that every
partition is equally likely.
Therefore, we did indeed solve
the same problem, and so this
is a legitimate alternative way
of getting to the answer.
And of course, it's reassuring
to check that this numerical
expression agrees with the
numerical expression we had
derived earlier.